all right let's go to the phones not
really a phone
via discord davidpakman.com
discord is how we now take calls for a
number of different reasons the quality
of the phone calls seems to be better
and we hear from more people
and it's just it's just working well
let's start today
with john from orange county california
john you're on the air all right um
well my question was going to be about
first i want to get your opinion on
whether you think it's worth it to have
people
like joe manchin and kristen cinema
in the senate when you say worth that do
you mean instead of a more liberal
democrat or instead of a republican
well i mean they essentially to me
it seems that their views are rather
reactionary
and that the actions that they take are
uh that way
well listen um you can look at the
percentages but they still mostly vote
with democrats so
this is something that comes up often
the solution
it's it's easier in many cases
to replace a republican with a democrat
and keep mansion in cinema
than it would be to get like a bernie
elected in west virginia so
so you have to remember they mostly
still are voting for democrats if a
republican defeats them
they'll never vote with democrats right
okay i understand that um then what i
was going to say
is do you think because they have voted
against very big things
right the most notable one to me would
be
uh the the 15 min minimum wage
right including the 15 minimum wage and
the covid relief bill yeah
so um do you think in 2022
it would be possible for them to be
primaried out or
it certainly could be possible for them
to be primaried out the question is then
do they lose to republicans i think the
answer with mansion is more likely yes
than with cinema
i see yeah i understand okay
thank you very much all right no problem
uh very important question i mean it's a
it's relevant to specific bills it's not
a it's not a trivial hypothetical
one of our sponsors is vincero watches
giving you fifteen percent off
a high quality wristwatch is the perfect
way to
elevate your style own at least one
watch
that makes you feel great when you put
it on you can often see me wearing
my ventura watch on the show mine is the
gunmetal
vessel model i'm a big fan of the
metallic look
of the face of the watch i like the
silicone strap
you won't find a better made watch for
this good a price
anywhere else when you put it on you
know you got more than you paid for
vincero believes in crafting super
quality watches from high-end materials
but selling them at fair prices which is
why they have over twenty six thousand
five star reviews and they stand behind
every watch they make with a one-year
return policy
and five-year warranty they'll give you
fifteen percent off everything in their
store and free shipping
at davidpakman.com watch use the coupon
code
pacman